[Music]
[Applause]
I forgot how fast
[Music]
will you wait for me
anybody
[Music]
away from me
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
hope you enjoyed that bit of flow I just
want to give a quick shout out to my man
Mufasa here for doing the camera work uh
Mufasa where can the good people find
you online Instagram YouTube and
Facebook at Fogo monster at Fuego
monster go check this man out his work
is awesome thanks again anytime work it
hey friends I hope you enjoyed checking
out that flow they just put in that
Plaza a little bit south of where I live
uh on the DC Maryland border and uh it
was such a big space that I took one
look at her and was like I need to shoot
there so uh big thanks to Mufasa for
shooting the video and big thanks to
ultra POI for sponsoring this video and
giving me an excuse to go out and
explore public spaces like that if you'd
like to grab a set of those orb POI Pro
LED contact POI that I was using in the
video you can do that by heading on over
to ultrapoi.com and using my special
promo code directs factor with a zero
instead of an O at checkout that gets
you a discount on your order and it
helps uh support the channel so
everybody wins thank you once again to
ultra POI for supporting my work
speaking of thank yous I owe some thank
yous to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyrotera light toys spin balls and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business friend of the
channel That is Becca becklenen thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission finally
this video would not be possible we're
not for the kind support of all of these
awesome people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very very
generous support if you out there
watching are not currently supporter but
you'd like to become one here's how you
can do that head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but even better than that you
will be helping me out in my mission to
bring POI spinning and flow Arts to the
whole wide world so go check that out
please and thank you
if you'd like to check out uh more
videos of my performances I will go
ahead and leave a link to a playlist of
those down in the description as well as
up here on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here uh because it's popular
amongst other viewers of my channel so
maybe give that a look as well thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon
peace